une colère l'entente contenu qui
éclatent tout à coup
les gilets jaunes ont convergé par
milliers vers paris bien déterminés à se
faire voir à se faire entendre des
autorités à mieux
jérôme mécanicien chez air france qui
est de plus en plus de mal à joindre les
deux bouts
une situation résumé en chiffres sur son
gilet au nom salaires qui n'augmentent
pas j'ai écrit 2 % d'augmentation en
cinq ans il ya tout le monde je pense
que le prix du carburant bas c'est la
goutte d'eau comme on dit qui a fait
déborder le vase
et là on en est à une baisse du pouvoir
d'achat que récente encore plus durement
bien des retraités comme daniel morin
très en colère contre le président ma
crainte c'est un banquier mais c'est ni
plus ni moins qu'un banquier et nous
prend vraiment pour des idiots et la
chercher vraiment ça devient
insupportable
les manifestants voulaient défiler place
de la concorde
non loin de l'assemblée nationale et du
palais présidentiel impensable pour les
autorités qui ont déployé plusieurs
milliers de policiers dans la capitale
pour les en empêcher
or les gilets jaunes ont investi les
champs elysées ils s'y sont installés
ont érigé des barricades
souvent enflammés ils ont défendu leur
position à coups de pavés avant d'en
être délogés
puis de recommencer un peu plus loin gaz
lacrymogènes et canons à eau contre
projectiles improvisé un air de champ de
bataille sur la plus belle avenue du
monde
des affrontements violents qui ont
choqué plus d'un manifestant on
s'attendait pas aujourd'hui à tous ces
débordements ces feux que ces terrasses
et c'est très dangereux c'est très
dangereux
au départ initiative pacifique venus de
la base le mouvement des gilets jaunes
est en train de donner lieu aux émeutes
les plus violentes de la présidence d'
emmanuel macron un mouvement d'autant
plus dangereux pour les autorités
françaises qu'il n'a pas de véritables
dirigeants avec qui négocier
les affrontements se sont poursuivis
toute la journée et une bonne partie de
la soirée
beaucoup de dommages et quelques
dizaines de blessés mais moins de
manifestants que samedi dernier huit
mille à paris selon les forces de
l'ordre
80000 dans toute la france mais leur
influence reste bien réelle selon un
récent sondage près de 80% des français
soutiennent les gilets jaunes et
considère leur action légitime
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada
paru